nasco già fuori siamo fuori siamo usciti
ai rigori ma certo che parte male l'anno
passato si doveva lanciare per forza di
testa beh sì sono abbiamo fatto un po di
casino è però ce l'abbiamo fatta siamo
felici di prigione ciccio che ebbero la
centralissima grano è stata una fuga
veramente figaro in chiaro shit caccia
al rigore ma che aveva chat e mezzo
all'erbetta non dovrebbero vederci
l'erba è alta capito e mi vieni qua
processo dove sei
io sto passando in mezzo ai cespugli
velocissima tipo ninja sony già
bravissimo quanta gente c'è pieno ho
buttato giù lo stelo lo stesso tipo i
panni come si può ammazzare pur in due
questo dobbiamo fare affari in due io
con la sinistra a destra aspetta aspetta
vai per effetto bravissimo sei stato
bravissimo mi è piaciuto assieme a
questi come hanno fatto ad arrivare fino
a qua ad aspettare chi guarda e tu mi sa
che di far fuori dall altro questa volta
altro seconda non può fare scendere e
salire rimango qua la faccio fuori
questa il mio 31 23 ai tempi di un
licantropo mora ma adoro ero lì
imbalsamato quando vuoi all right un
treno ora bravo beh stando al ponte dai
vuoi dirmi che non lo stanno
sorvegliando questo ponte sembra di no
possiamo passare tranquillamente vale
sempre tu il primo a essere termine per
primo lo guarda come non lo stanno
sorvegliando nessuno porca vacca 6 sotto
il ponte no vabbè adesso c'è l'apertura
la scaletta del disco costo ben passa
sopra punto sotto il ponte come fare lei
sopra il ponte life ascolto the butto
aggiunti poi prendiamo la mano guido vai
fuori bastardo
da un metro entro io entro nel sedile
passeggeri tu guidi si parlò allora
allora sì che non si riconosce nel suo
destino investito ma che poi è stata la
cosa più bella è che poteva state è
stato bellissimo
va bene una parte opposta in questa
negozi a sinistra per la che a destra
dritto dritto
resiste bravissimo a voci così si guida
ciccio bravo mi sei piaciuto alla guida
può ribaltare il risultato a quanto pare
confermare o ribaltare il risultato hero
la macchina non so che tipo festa anche
questo bastardo ma stiamo buttando nel
dirupo nei di noi può nuovo noti hanno
preso i cani viene fuori con la garanzia
che ansia
devo prendere io al volo che il
responsabilità ciò
e vabbè io lascio dalla fine con lei
lasciato hanno fatto una prigione dentro
l'amazzone se alla fine non sarebbe figo
alza il tronco amico mio
poi alzarsi allora a puntare su di me e
non io sono solo un alzatore di
polemiche al progetto il mio raso quel
fatto tre fiere o che questi hanno
problemi un processo di pesci st vestito
facevo esatto è diventato minecraft
beschi e io lastrico
ok protette un pesce qualcuno ma no ma
perché mostrato il mio
ecco allora il tasto sinistro fai questo
fai prendi ricavava all'asta dal suo
lancio lancia loggia
anch'io come si fa senti i pesci
supereroi non riusciamo a
a farli fuori quindi dovevamo costruire
una fiocina per pescare non pescarli che
amano ma perché noi siamo skillati ne
voleva andare che è mai ordinato una
fiocina su amazon cioè un po amicizia un
pestone ma sono pochissimi pesce bait
presso altro che click day
senti ma io sono vegano posso mangiare
una fede a mantova aperta sto scherzando
ma io non ho capi io non ho che fosse
abbiamo passeggiato troppo nella
cinematica me non ho capito ma sto arbe
in cosa ci allarma ecco niente a porta a
porta posto piegando per me non sto
spiegando mi chiama donna poverino
così niente qui gara molta tranquillità
seduti o confine chi è sacra
ora è tutto chiaro almeno sappiamo che
stiamo andando a fare no perché non
capivo chiaro sto tizio capito che bella
l'area di libertà
sento puzza di natale però sarà che una
fattoria larice like siamo usciti la
prigione già stiamo facendo nel franzino
succederà lente e lo sto guardando il
telegiornale dove dicono che siamo
invasi e noi siamo lì si va bene è una
tipa è nonna è la mia preferita tematica
fucile a pompa e la madonna fucile a
pompa tavolo o ecco entra prima tu
secondo me ci becchiamo un altri file
l'occhio ora nel testicolo destro un
giorno ok
bisogna facciamo bene qua però tocca
dentro l'acqua hoc che io io entro
viveva bene per queste cose qua emettono
apposta proprio per entrarci qua eh si
io entra dalla finestra del piano di
sopra mongoloide guardali rifacciamo
certe hanno una casa bellissima ci sono
rocco rompi e ora un po il quadro di
sopra e tu prendi la mano perché se lei
stessa su 32 sì ma se si alza 81 non
posso e mai una vera la puoi andare a
papa come sto ragionando da criminale ma
un po tutti e due della madonna
no no no no ferma ferma è una vecchia
cosa faccio beh ma veloce barravecchia
mia decima don ciccio madonna dovevate
mandarla fuori la finestra cerchi the
lady chiamano
o magari no ma lo re scusa ma è maestra
della figlia da un classico ciccione li
dai tu mi stanno sanguinando gli occhi
intelligenti ci sono è ammazza ammazza
ammazza sto dicendo una mazza napoli na
arrivo ciccio arrivo a specchio un disco
con questo sito eccolo no non ti sparano
di sparare sentire se poi siamo stati
bravi da e circondi anni che era di
stoffa c'è più paura tutta una come noi
siamo buoni alla fine dall'altra ducci
miccia bene questa accelerata con
l'armadio addirittura è tutto questo che
prenda il 2 vestibilità un poverino come
escono hanno fame di più comunque c'è
già ora mario sei o mi sono chiuso
dentro che se non vi va di passare i
nostri ma se una donna e non f
già mi hanno censurato il primo arrivo
del video riportato vai di guardare
michael jackson non esatta non è
esattamente proprio questo gusto per le
camicie un po strane treni il furgone è
questo il furgone sono sicurissimi che
stiamo percorrendo è sta parlando di te
ciccio saperne andavamo il campo allora
se qua dentro non c'è il furgone è un
casino perché non so tutto allora poteva
aprire da solo benissimo bastava che
apriamo una penale è solo stata aperta
spingi sei te alla discesa sali dentro
dentro dietro è io sangue come non detto
sono liberi sono liberi l'hanno fatta a
liberarsi questo è sono vecchi con le
palle no no no no miccia delle volte ma
come quando fate a liberarsi per questo
passo
vai vai vai vado io sto qui da chi sta
guidando tu tu tu io solo dietro tema
che mi faccio guidare un po che non sia
solo la transizione
voglio guidare fatevi guidare vi prego
da 21 20 23 stava andando la musica
giusta la faccia ma è falso ma la crus
pari a guido mamma mia che gioco dei
fatti di sparare c'è il clacson
addirittura è indovina indovina chi devi
sparare aspettano aggiungo un po di
adrenalina e tutto questo
tagliati alla madonna
sto caricando una madonna fosse arrivato
un camion fortissimo c'è un posto di
blocco
siamo nella cacca tra quello mischia ma
questi i posti di blocco non li sanno
fare
porca vacca vieni vieni qui vieni qui
dice ci sono ci sono quanto vanno
infatti occhio o oddio questi che stanno
a farli s'impongono dopo la strada
chiodata no porca vacca brutta roba
[Applauso]
dobbiamo uscire dai più dentro il fiume
sai chi sono io a dover dare la chiamò a
casa di mia zia che è un casino
la barca scala barca con la barca dalla
palude devi darmi una mano e vita mia
mano a spingere qua dobbiamo a spingere
invece vai
ci voleva una barca hanno trovato a casa
che cercano un culo hanno trovato una
barca a caso va bene ci sei
se ci sei ecco con la rossa e mezza per
evitare di prenderlo ok ai premi per me
ok
porca vacca che giro abbia fatto oddio
madonna oddio la musica ciccio
no vedo io ti do io
e ancora troppo tardi metteste mussi
perfetta si diramano ma lo davano no c
ciao io di zio sotto temuto allora non
sono morto ancora arrivati vario ma
quanta sfiga tutte insieme
ci vorrebbe una mia mano alla mano
eccoci in giro ma che bello avere le
sono morti così dire il bellissimo ce
l'ha fatta
[Musica]
che succede
ecco mi parlò insomar cavo resti
comprare dei cereali che si chiamano ugo
te io se hugo mi mancano mamma metti il
sugo a hugo e fu così mamma c'è qualche
evaso di prigione dietro qua no eh sì
sicuro si è cercato da mio figlio e sto
qua meno male che non sa se non ha preso
da te
ajax
stiamo andando a casa dei tuoi ma se
abitate in una roulotte ma comunque da
pazzi perché sono feriti va bene
concludo quei ragazzi l'episodio di a
way out spero vi sia piaciuto si stava
avvicinando sempre di più al finale che
arriverà tra poco è però vi stia
piacendo a me da morire ma grazie a dio
ciccio che fortunatamente fa una cazzata
dopo l'altra quindi diventa ancora più
figo è bellissimo è un compagno come lui
giura veramente sembra mio compagno di
banco a scuola non azzeccava una prova
beh ragazzi si facevano sempre piacere
ma bisogna evidenziare che diamo seguito
da ragazzi
[Musica]